the opening scene features an
introverted man named Seth Donaldson who
works at an animal control center that
takes in and eventually euthanizes stray
animals being a socially awkward person
he has no friends and lives alone in his
apartment his daily routine is limited
to going to work and returning home oh
God am I Seth one day while returning
home on a Metro Bus he recognizes his
former High School classmate Holly
Garling whom he always had a crush on he
strikes up a convers with her but he is
unable to gather enough courage to ask
her out on a date upon arriving back
home Seth begins researching Holly on
social media specifically by memorizing
her likes and dislikes likes travel
exercise and funny people dislikes Seth
what the the following day at work
he seeks advice from a security guard
named Nate who tells him to be confident
and approach her hearing this Seth
stages an encounter with Holly at the
restaurant where she works as a waitress
knowing that she likes music and concert
s he offers her a ticket to go with him
however she feels really uncomfortable
and turns him down later that night
Holly returns back home and tells her
roommate and best friend Claire about
Seth in the midst of their conversation
she receives a drunken phone call from
her ex-boyfriend named Eric when Holly
senses that he's in an inebriated State
she hangs up the call the next day she
receives a bouquet of flowers at her
workplace which she assumes to be from
Eric as a result she goes to the bar
where he works un boted of the fact that
Seth is tailing her Holly then talks to
Eric asking him not to make any more
efforts because everything is over
between them however he still wants a
chance to make things right I'll never
drink again babe a short while later
Holly walks out to light a cigarette and
this is when Seth approaches her he
tries his best to ask her out on a date
but fails when he starts getting
aggressive Eric beats him up before
throwing him off the premises although
Seth is injured he manages to steal
Holly's diary which she had dropped on
the ground Seth then spends the next few
days reading her diary in which she used
to write her journal on a daily basis
this allows him to learn more
information about her dear diary Seth is
an what one day at work Seth's
attention is caught by a restricted
basement door in an abandoned wing of
the animal shelter intrigued he grabs a
flashlight and heads downstairs only to
discover a trap door that leads to a
secret room this Revelation strikes him
with an idea and decides to construct a
steel cage in addition he stealthily
steals an anesthetic drug that is used
to subdue the harmful pets he firstly
tests the drug on himself rendering
himself unconscious for a while when he
wakes up he says damn that was some good
one evening Seth secretly Tails
Holly to her residence breaks inside and
sedates her with the anesthetic drug he
then packs her up in a large box and
takes her to the secret room within his
workplace upon arriving at the pet
clinic he is stopped by Nate who
inquires about the content in the Box
Seth tries to pass him by by pretending
it's an emergency delivery just then
Holly moves inside creating a sound this
raises Nate's suspicion prompting him to
walk near the box at the same time he
hears another sound coming from the
ceiling which makes him believe that it
is their old AC it is a huge relief for
Seth who then takes her to the basement
and locks her inside the cage after some
time Holly regains her Consciousness and
freaks out to find herself there she
screams to be released but her voice
goes unheard as a result she is left
with no choice but to stay there in the
darkness for the whole night the
following day Seth comes to visit her
with some food and a bed pan she
requests to be released but he asserts
that he has captured her in order to
save her rather than harming her Seth
then departs leaving Holly alone for the
next few days by the time he returns she
is already overwhelmed by weakness he
provides her with some more food and
water before abandoning her again while
walking out of the basement Nate catches
him and questions his purpose of
entering the restricted area however
Seth manages to slip away with the help
of a lie over the slow passage of days
Holly adjusts to her period of captivity
by talking to her imaginary former
roommate she is also forced to use the
toilet seat given by Seth while
urinating a rat creeps near her feet
which startles her for a moment as a
result she ruthlessly Stomps it with her
bare feet killing it brutally the next
time when Seth visits her she asks if he
wants to assault her or kill her in
response he says he won't touch her
inappropriately but might kill her if
circumstances demand he then sits in
front of her and explains how he fell
for her the moment he saw her during
high school as their conversation
unfolds Seth asks about Claire he
recounts how he overheard her talking to
her best friend despite being alone in
the room he then asks if she still sees
CLA the latter answers in the negative
even though she hallucinates her behind
him following this Seth takes out
Holly's diary from his bag and reveals
that he is aware of all her Secrets he
begins to remind everything that she is
mentioned in the diary taking us all
back to the past one night Holly
discovered about her boyfriend's secret
affair with her best friend which broke
her heart she then confronted CLA about
the same during a car ride in her anger
Holly continued accelerating the car
ignoring cla's apology and her plea to
stop shortly after they were hit by a
truck causing them to be severely
wounded when Holly learned that CLA was
still alive she grabbed a pointed glass
Shard and stabbed right into her eyes
resulting in her death here it is
revealed that Claire whom we have seen
throughout the movie is just Holly's
hallucination in reality she is talking
to herself like a psycho as opposed to
whatever she was doing before I guess
since that traumatic incident Holly has
committed a series of gruesome murders
and written about all of them in her
journal she tries to fool him saying
that she's a writer and the written
content is based on fiction however Seth
discloses that he's been stalking her
for a long time and that he has
witnessed several murders with his own
eyes he tries to convince her that he's
here to save her from committing any
more crimes because he loves her over
the next several days the two engage in
psychological mind games against each
other as Holly begins to slip details to
draw Seth in he believes that she
committed the other murders out of guilt
for not being caught over CLA but the
latter count CS that she kills for
pleasure one day holly threatens to
commit the unthinkable and frame him for
her murder she even bangs her head
against the steel bars resulting in her
bleeding but Seth Remains unfaced the
Same Day Nate catches Seth walking out
of the restricted basement sensing
something am Miss he slowly heads
downstairs and is shocked to discover
the imprisoned lady Holly seizes the
moment and urges Nate to quickly find a
tool to break the lock while
comprehending the situation Seth returns
back with some food in an unexpected
turn of events Holly signals Seth to
kill the guard she also distracts Nate
earning enough time for Seth to attack
him from behind at Holly's urging he
knocks him down and then smashes his
head with a cinder block moments later
Seth gets overwhelmed with guilt and
breaks down in tears realizing that he
has now become a murderer too but Holly
calms him down and guides him with the
process of disposing of the body
following her instruction he mutilates
the dead body into pieces and feeds it
to the pets in the clinic he also pulls
out all of his teeth in order to prevent
the police from recognizing nade Seth
says from here on out you call me the
tooth fairy in the aftermath of this
event the police officers led by
detective miara take charge of the
investigation subjecting Seth to
interrogation while questioning him
about Nate's disappearance the detective
becomes suspicious of Seth because the
details he mentions do not match what
they have found in the ensuing days
Holly continues her ongoing manipulation
of Seth's mind saying that they are
meant to be lovers because they both
share a common pleasure of killing
people he tries not to fall for her mind
games but she keeps on making it hard
for him she continues to talk to him
with love and even tries to seduce him
just as a part of her manipulative
strategy at one point she blackmails him
to prove his love to her by cutting off
one of his fingers Seth adamantly
refuses to do so and chooses to walk
away right then holid declares that she
is no more than a pet for him and asks
him not to come back to her again Seth
then heads to the bathroom where he
vents his frustration for not being able
to figure out what to do after
contemplating for a while he returns
back to the basement and agrees to
sacrifice his finger for his love he
then proceeds with the gruesome process
which causes him a lot of pain
unsurprisingly Holly takes full
advantage of this opportunity she grabs
his knife and threatens to commit the
unthinkable if he does not release her
with no other choice he unlocks the door
finally letting her out following this
she pushes him against the wall and
mentions that she now believes that he
loves her she also kisses him but the
situation takes an unexpected turn when
Holly reveals her Sinister form and
slits his throat before leaving the
scene then fast forwards to the Future
depicting that Holly is back together
with Eric we also learn that her
fictional events from her journal are
being published by a vanity press one
morning Eric receives a message from a
random girl which Holly happens to see
despite realizing that he is cheating on
her again she opts not to hurt him later
that day she heads to an abandoned
warehouse where it is revealed that she
has imprisoned Seth in the same cage
still alive but horribly mutilated and
tortured she thanks him for allowing her
to take out all of her murderous
impulses on him she says that Seth
indeed saved her as he promised to do
through his sacrifice the movie ends as
the two hold hands as Holly professor is
her love for him subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching